it all landed well bonjour brad pitt and
nicole paltrowski
the two have people talking after
landing in paris wednesday morning to
later board a private jet
i'm pretty grateful for that where are
they headed well we'll tell you
we'll go see what happens an eyewitness
says the german model was the first to
arrive at the paris airport from berlin
germany
and was seen waiting for brad's flight
that was coming in from the united
states
once the actor arrived they were quote
driving in a chauffeured vehicle
that took them to the airport for their
next flight to the south of france
the duo both showed up casual brad wore
a green sweater
army green pants white shoes dark shades
and a news boy
while nicole also rocked a hat shades
leather jacket
baggy tan pants and black ankle boots
they both wore masks upon boarding the
aircraft
the eyewitness adds they were very low
key and entered the plane quickly
once brad and nicole arrived in the
south of france the eyewitness saw brad
take off his sweater
while nicole had taken off her hat while
little is known about nicole who goes by
the modeling name nico mary
she was recently featured on the
september issue of elle germany
meanwhile brad has been dodging romance
rumors since his split from angelina
jolie in 2016.
i'm blissfully naive and i'm going to
stay that way last december he talked to
the new york times about the women
he's been romantically linked to since
his breakup saying quote
i don't know how many women they've said
i've been dating the last two or three
years
and none of it is true